and as you get bigger and bigger with  your business it is very very important  to follow what's going on in the news  now here's a problem a lot of people  will say well dude I don't know who do I  follow I don't trust CNN I don't trust  Fox I'll let you see you know all these  people that say they don't trust this I  will tell you if there isn't Tom you  know I think you would vouch for this as  well if there is someone you ought to  subscribe this is not a sponsorship  we're not making money off of this they  don't send us nothing go subscribe to  Wall Street Journal and read it every  day okay I think the Wall Street Journal  if there's anything they do they're the  most fairest ones that will call out  [ __ ] on the left and the right and the  middle I think they're straight up so my  suggestion is do follow a publication  that you do trust and I would say uh I  put Wall Street Journal the first